welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham Aziz and today
I'm pretty I'm gonna be really annoyed
if I didn't remember what I'm pretty
sure I'm joined by the very first
Brummie on the recruitment roller
coaster podcast and that is Tony Bates
who is a managing director for idec's
consulting thank you for joining me sir
thank you very much how I I'm very well
good becomes the six most investable
city in Europe or straight in there just
see if I get in or promote Birmingham
here my class let you know where I like
to start let's get into it mate how the
hell did you get into recruitment well
quite unusual because I wanted to get
into it yeah from the start so I got
turned down for recruitment job when I
was twenty okay no blazer on I wasn't
smart enough for the guys to look why
have you come with no blaze I said you
can't do recruitment like that what do
you wear literally just trousers and a
shirt and the guy rejected me and I'm
but it kind of motivated me to get back
into it then he said I didn't have the
style skills and no blazer so when it
got the South Blazer really tried again
I applied for a role in the newspaper
really old school that's how long been
doing it is Christ did six months or a
small independent firm in financial
services which is where I worked
previously and then joined a national
that kept approaching my friend works at
a national firm yeah in the same market
and every time you filled a job that I
didn't need phone me up and go you know
that job you're working I've just filled
it bastard so that was his way of
recruiting me look we've got all the
jobs and all the candidates come work
for us that's class well then went to
work for read these five years there
yeah and then set up idec's we've mapped
green many moons of going here and we
could make so let's would definitely
uncover that story made that journey so
why that why did you want to get into
recruitment like how did that come about
well I think I've always worked in I've
always been in team environments I've
always been around people my neck has
always been quite wide okay and I've
always been interested genuinely this
isn't just a spiel yeah I mean how
people got to where they got to okay you
know from a background that wasn't that
a fluent sort trying to work out
how can I be yeah how can where you are
yeah yeah you know what why am i living
here and what do to get there so I
explored reasons as to how they've got
the career that were that they were out
really and I like that aspects of it
really so I go into recruitment yeah
because my questioning skills had always
been the case of trying to find out how
people had got where they got to could
then carry out in the recruitment job
anyway yeah to actually put passive
interest in what else did you free that
curiosity then did you start reading
books and things like that or was NF it
or was it just that real curiosity that
obviously helped you in recruitment
massively from from day one well don't
he got rid of books a lot about 30 so
that was a case I think at the time it
was just you you know it was a time
before Facebook yeah again I'm showing
my age I apologize for that
but it was different then so a lot of
people are soaring recruitment were
generally successful yeah yeah you
didn't have as much access to
information absolutely so I wanted that
success but I also knew that I had a
skill of of socializing I could walk
into a football changing room not know
any players and I wouldn't be the best
player there but I could still be able
to network and be able to find my way in
that group and I knew that I could carry
that into business I think there's a lot
of similarities with sports yeah and
business you know you walk into an
office for the first time you know you
can be intimidating yeah I mean it's the
same when you walk into a football
changing room yeah and you got the guy
that's a brilliant footballer you've got
your big tackle you got all these deer
and you adapt yeah I think that's why I
knew I'd be good at recruitment because
the ability to do that like that like
that so okay so let's break down sort of
a bit your recruitment Chris obviously
you've been of cix now that you really
found with a number of directors it's
like that's over 10 years now isn't it
we just talking about that so let's talk
a bit before then so you worked for a
small boutique agency that was your
first job right costs Carlton it back a
bit well my foot my first job was in
financial service area yes I've got a
job and got qualified in the industry
that I know recruit okay so that's the
option there needed to be a para poner
mm-hmm which is financial services or go
into recruitment so I took the option of
going to recruitment of that yeah
there's a real you know really big
decision at the time you know certain
decisions in your life that kind of take
you in different directions
at that point I remember you know
talking to lots of different people
about what I should do when every one of
the different opinions or just went
followed the gut and went into
recruitment at that point so and now see
yeah that's interesting and then it was
a small BT can see that you joined
initially yeah very small it was what 20
20 employees at the time I was the first
one to do financial services in that
really I said oh that's yeah completely
cold desk you know at that point we were
still faxing Jesus Christ on our minds
that's not good I mean you know still
fax you see reason that sort of stuff so
it was it was it was tough but a
straightaway I loved he really loved
what he loved by it um well I'm a member
of specific networks in financial
services and yeah and there was a guy
there who was was a director of a
business he was my boss bite you know
yeah it was Tim runs at the ladder and
it's my first day I had him as a
candidate so suddenly the guy that's
been directing me and telling me I
should be hard and doing all this yeah
I'm suddenly then direct in his career
class and he listened and respected me
mmm you know for suddenly when you you
know you were in the lower levels within
financial services certainly I felt that
I had this ability to kind of guide
people and and talk to people on their
level and I love that aspects of it
really I knew that every time I spoke to
a candidate or a client this still
stands now I genuinely wanted to help
them you know now that sounds really
corny wasn't a balance getting a for as
I said I was trying to work out right
how can I make your career better I like
and even now when I see people that I've
done that it was all about the career
move not the job and I love that aspect
of it and I still get a buzz now even
talking about it now you know and I
think this in recruitment it's you know
the good people and there are a lot of
good people have you seen on this pod or
listened to on this podcast which has
been amazing to hear some of the quality
that's out there yeah but the good
people the ones that actually try and
guide people's careers like they're just
looking to find him a job at the
instance yeah that's what I loved and I
did that straightaway and that's okay
too so now was to you is there what five
months or so did you say yeah and then
you air and then you went to read for
like five years
yeah I was there for five months and as
I say much
my friend God called Chris astal yeah
was working he'd been doing that that
sort of mark was trying to get me to
move across there and I'll say no and I
want to be loyal yeah I hadn't moved
jobs and literally was teasing me every
time going yeah we've just got like ten
jobs in and I was phoning man one
hundred people had never heard of us to
try and get one job I'm just getting all
these jobs Gordon and every time he got
a job and he'd phone me and tell me and
say look I've just got this brilliant
job you'd love to work this one you know
that so yeah he's horrible and funny at
the same so obviously then are then went
across and and work for Radian and he
was there for like five yeah 5 years
Amin HD I grew the team and then we set
up a mortgage division okay I oversaw
insurance had about 25 people in the end
ok covered in about two point comedy
let's unpack that that may off in there
there'll be loads of stuff in there so
that's the first observation then
because this help me and my recruitment
Chrissy I worked in insurance then
recruited insurance that massively helps
which it seems like it helps you day one
yeah so now so for people that don't
have that experience in the industry I'm
sure so have you recruited people now
that haven't worked in financial
services that and now in your team my
time machine lluvia yes so what's from
your cuz because you've worked in
industry how do you then encourage them
to get immersed in the financial
services in the actual industry that
they're recruiting is anything that you
tell them to do straight off the bat to
get involved well in terms of
understanding the industry I think you
need to understand the people in the
industry more than anything clearly
reports him to who in the structure of
it I don't think it's all about
understanding the intricacies of what a
pension ease or okay an investment is
about understanding how the structures
of the businesses work and and what
their cultures are it's changed a lot
through the years doesn't it in terms of
what you need to know and what you do in
recruitment but the people that I
recruit now aren't you know some of our
most successful never worked in the
industry yeah but I know you speak a lot
but ality but you know what I try and
look for and recruiters now he's more
about how they bounce back you know I
think we recruited one individual
who had got a masters being traveling
you know the amazing sort of life
everything perfect and then when she got
some you know a drop-off or a job even a
job drop-off he broke broke her heart
she couldn't deal with it be ever dealt
with adversity yeah so I think mindset
but I look for people now it's not about
industry knowledge it's about how do you
deal with that versity and how do you
bounce back from adversity because as
you know you get a lot of knock backs
and we cry a big fire and if you can't
deal with them yeah you're not gonna go
anywhere so so you I don't think you
necessarily I'm sure I don't you need to
have worked in the industry nough so
it's more about character and
personality for me that's a fact that
makes people success and then yeah it's
just about picking up the nuances within
your industry buzz beacons people yeah
we're fortunate the motor we've got a
lot of people with lots of knowledge I
think we've done 50% of our business
have been with us longer than five years
yeah straight away people can tap into
yeah I know a lot of people listening
will probably have that knowledge around
them yes it's like tap into that again
straightaway so I think there's a
team-based approach to helping people
you know we've got enough candidates and
clients work come to us and it's the
whole team that helps them you've got an
individual's after the desk but the
knowledge is not just from that
individual it's from the whole team yeah
and the years of experience that they've
got really so there's lots of the bigger
you are the more experience you have
I think when you first are in your first
recruit you might need that financial
services experience but as you go
through time yeah if you're sure less
important so let's talk a bit about the
this time Reed then so like obviously
you yeah like so what was going on in
like the first 12 to 24 months like so
did you start did you so this guy I was
telling you I got this job blah blah
blah and then you join there obviously
so then was you're working under him oh
no no what we're working alongside each
other all right we will manage Alice for
about a year and a half it's you to
building meet me and one of the guy yet
but we did very little really for it for
a year and a half really and that kind
of made me realize that the importance
of having management really what do you
mean by didn't do very little
well we a bit lazy well yeah I don't
think we were in a small office there's
no real read we're just one team you
know yeah they got loads of difference
so we you know we didn't see anyone
being successful so we didn't know what
success was and part of everything in
life is and
standing and seeing success and yeah and
that's what makes you want to grab it
more so we didn't have access to seeing
anybody do well the person doing one at
that point was doing 50 60 grand so we
were just you know you just tried to be
better than the worst person doesn't
doesn't create a successful environment
really yeah and then that's when Matt
green who's now my business partner came
in managed us and took us a level and
encouraged us through okay cool so what
so what how were those so first to
first-year and Arthur when you didn't
have a manager like was what was you
doing like was just so would you
straighten their building and debts be
there and everything like yeah building
a despot oh I was I was I was running
blind for the first years yeah I had no
no one telling me what to do no guidance
in terms of so I just did what I thought
I could should do which is just phone
people and really and that worked you
know I've had quite a bit of success and
and started to build a really strong
network in financial services and I
worked there until the recession and
that was anyone that worked through that
was was the most challenge in time ever
and with that was just a set of high
decks with Matt I was gonna join Matt
sorry and then the recession hit really
walked away from was a director level at
read everything was gone while I was
kind of the read golden boy at one point
you know really a fastest-growing
division most profitable I walked away
from that job to set up I decks
everything it was glorious and then the
recession hit and they were dark days
and I need three remember calling around
and saying you know talking about
recruitment and people were laughing
down the phone saying haven't you seen
the news so that was a seriously you
know imagine going from big director
role in setting up pause in a really
shabby office with leaks and nowhere so
I've gone from you know a really man
united strike or I guess to Grimsby
reserves very quickly Wow yeah well it
was the best thing that happened yes
character will go into that but I just
want to just talk a bit about before
that because there there'll be loads of
learnings in that so light so as you
said so year and a half but those three
years your blind leading the blind right
target smoke oh yeah exactly and then
and then but by the time we left you
just saying obviously grew this team
talk to what was it you said I think you
mentioned the figure what did you we
have in the end we have 24 people 2.4
million so you know for re that yeah
that's a hundred let's talk a bit about
how you got to that point yeah Lester so
what so firstly they so a big part of it
was he didn't have a manager so you had
no guidance as to why it's this is how
you're gonna grow this desta to that so
that was a big factor obviously he
didn't have a manager absolutely yeah so
so first I guess so what did you learn
over those sort of first three years
that's worth talking about over those
first three years where you felt yeah
you're just doing what you thought was
best
yeah I feel I think the first three
years taught me that you need structure
mmm you know you need you need a leader
that inspires mmm you know I think you
know when Matt did join we had a leader
that inspired us and showed us away and
I mentioned earlier about seeing success
you know he wanted someone that was
saying right this is what you can have
if you do this if you build as much this
is what you can have and suddenly made
it real for the first few years I think
keep made me realize that you need to
visualize what you're trying to achieve
you know talking about doing five
interviews or six interviews a week
really doesn't mean anything unless you
break it down to actually what that well
asked achieving those target sees and
that's what I learnt really is you need
to work out where you go in and break
down when you need to do on a daily
basis to achieve that goal yeah okay I
like that and for you I mean it seems
like innately it was about yeah
generally helping people like what is
that all it's always about money isn't
that really like in the recruitment
world it's like yeah you know my name is
so like was that always attached was it
always attached to money with you at
that stage or was it what that you could
actually build and what you could create
and the difference you can make
absolutely I think you know when you get
you first but the money makes a huge
difference but it comes down to more
than that in repair when you weren't
your first big bonus then you know they
all it's different so I certainly think
the element of helping people and being
being someone yeah
you know that that was a big thing for
me is being someone and being someone
I walked down the street and people say
how you doing Anakin I've placed them
two years ago or yeah the chief exec or
a director of business walking down the
road and saying hello yeah you know that
was kind of that was a real motivation
for me and also I think people
respecting the work that I did and the
way that I worked as well on the way
they operated that was a big drive yeah
so that's yeah that's interesting so
obviously you got the monetary there but
and then it's everything that comes with
that that really drove you in and that
was the sort of Northstar that you
needed to see what what is this what is
these daily things I'm doing and it's
helping me get to that point absolutely
yeah money's money's not everything is
it really but then when I got given a
manager's role but Reid and then it was
a different part then I wanted to help
other people and make them better
yeah and I wanted us all to go on this
journey you know as always catching a
football team yeah it was about right
this is what we're doing lads the
world's against us yeah poor lads and
lassies yeah let's do it
our target is for the year the targets
for the week and when we get there we
celebrate together and we joy yeah all
right so so those three years Matt came
in made such a difference and then the
next two years it seems like then so
you've got that managers face and then
you really grew this team and was really
successful so so firstly did you know
that you wanted to be a manager because
I see a lot of people get forced down
that route light so up until that point
light was your gorilla yeah it was it
was always at the top billow and I do
believe that not every Top Billing makes
a good manager but I think I was always
the outspoken one yeah so I could I
think actually people would listen to me
I think if I agreed with something I
didn't agree with something they listen
to me so I guess I was the the naughty
boy that was made
prefect and it worked yeah and then did
they say we're making you a manager yeah
yeah so manage this team so I was
complaining about a lot of things and
the way we operated and I said will you
manage it then it was mainly different
yeah and I made the difference really
and grew you know and then I realized
that I think you know there's different
ways of managing people but I realize
that did have a bit of a knack for it I
don't know how it wasn't and then you
read the books and then you go to
different
training courses and then you adapt it
and and you know ultimately try and do
right by yeah by um so yeah okay so for
you then for your experience as you said
like there's there'll be a lot of
builders out there that aren't made to
be managers or forced and really those
things like what any advice for people
to adapt to that new manager role that
they're now find themselves in or
anything that that's worth talking about
uh yeah I think recruitment generally I
think don't get too carried away with
your own sense of importance made it I
really believe that I think I've seen
their laughs I've seen recruiters that
can you know double treble quadruple
their earnings in a short space of time
and their personality changes of who
they are because money just change it
isn't it and I think I think it's the
same when you go from being a consultant
to manager you know you still doesn't
make you better than anybody else and
the worst managers I've seen in
recruitment of those that get promoted
and suddenly think they're better than
everyone else listen to me because I'm
your boss and I'm better than you
yeah that's not the case when you do you
think that but you see there's a point
when you start billing and you feel
yourself changing it you think you know
and then if you've got good people
around either ground you yeah and
certainly I think it's really important
certainly we try and do it with guys at
our place the billion big you know still
be you don't you're not better than
anybody else based I really like that
how much you wanna know how much you
build yeah and I think you know going
back to the question of advice to people
going into management yeah still be you
and still do the right things and don't
think you better than anyone else and is
she doing a you're the person that has
to make decisions yeah and that's really
good advice
so then how did how did you go about
ramping up that team then like in those
two years right so you obviously as you
said will became one of the key parts of
a really profitable team and Reid and
any learnings for that in terms of cuz I
get a lot of questions around our
Haitian can you ask people about what
Keith and I know you touched on it but
we can talk about it now this or key
things to look at as to what makes a
good recruiter and these things because
that you must have got you're hiring
right to get the team up to that point
right obviously there's loads of odd
things once they're in the Train and all
that yeah but we are how did you then
end up getting the right people into the
Tim well the recruitment aspect was
based around it really was based on
personality yeah I looked at a CV but I
really do believe that you hire people
based on who they are as it just sounds
really obvious but I think people can
get carried away with school structure
there's gobies there's some key things
you've got a lookout that you know that
you want yeah well I want I want someone
that has had and it sounds terrible
thing to happen but all the all the
successful people in the crew as I know
I've had something really bad happen to
him in the line for the bad look for the
bad things happen to people look at the
top top billa's in my in our business
yeah and they've all out you know
difficult times in life yeah and they
deal with it and they overcome it and
they're become better for it so we all
have challenges to face and I think it's
the people that can demonstrate to me
that they've had some really challenging
to overcome and they've come through it
as a better individual they're the guys
that are successful in recruitment and
that's a really basic we have so many
knock backs and setbacks in group but if
you can't deal with those you don't
learn to enjoy them which I'm a that
sounds real even more weird yeah I
actually enjoy failing uh yeah and I've
trying is still in other guys to enjoy
failure because if you enjoy failure
because you know you've learnt from it
yeah the jobs great yeah you know it's
not about all the successes it's right
try something new fail I mean if you can
overcome that any better for it and I
think we're in an environment in a world
where people are scared to make mistakes
yeah to say the wrong thing yeah so
going back to the question in terms of
recruitment I'm looking for people that
have tried something failed hmm but got
back up and learn from and become better
from it so how how do you how do you
test that in an interview scenario
because I'd be a lot of managers list
and I'll get that yeah how did you find
that how do you find that in someone
well simply ask the question as you know
whether it's in work or out sort of
where what's the biggest challenge
you've overcome and taught you through
that process how did it make you feel
yeah react
make them live that failure I assume
crying
[Laughter]
we are gloriously in the end of it but
you know you be interesting for anyone
listening really is to think about the
top three builders in your business and
I would imagine you know I haven't done
any family fortune surveys but I would
imagine that if you look at their life
from what they've been through I bet
they've had some big hits mmm big hit so
knocked them down and they've got back
up and I think if we can all as
recruitment leave recruitment in just
what's been your big hit
ah you can't ask me this question well
you know from a from a personal
perspective you know it's not a sub
story but you know a difficult issue and
okay talk to me mate share it you know
from a council estate
yeah I mean which was pretty rough I
remember first going to a really bad
shirt and tie and going to my first job
because I wanted to get out of the
counselors day really I had to fight
people to get to the bus to try and get
to my job so you know stuff like that
but you know that's not something sure
everybody's had those kind of things so
fun I've had knock backs you know not
getting the first recruitment job was
worse not back where I thought when I'm
gonna come back and show you know yeah
get myself a blazer when I've got enough
money to get myself a blade yeah and I
did that and and I can't remember the
guys name that interviewed me but if
he's listening today thank you to meet
you one day and stick my two years and
why doesn't say so cool I really like
that was a some really good insight and
he said what what else went on in those
last two years then as you said you got
it so how how were your did you always
bill until you left yeah yes I've always
I've always build I had one year where
it didn't bill and I found was that I
read or I know society okay and I felt
horrible really really I think you know
you Billings I don't gives you that kind
of little bit of level of respect and
yeah the managers have always seen in
recruitment that don't bill or at least
not bill but certainly bring in some
income or some opportunities or some
leads
you know you go what you're doing yeah
you're doing so the last two years well
I think one of what it did well what
we've done while idec's really in terms
of managing he's create an environment
for people to succeed mmm that is that
he's big you know we we surveyed people
on our database recently and the biggest
driver for people joining the business
now was culture you know what salary it
wasn't anything like that so it's
culture so Pete what people want now and
what people look for when they join the
business people one a good culture
someone where the manager wants them to
be successful what happens to be
successful show them what they need to
do just so right you've got to do these
KPI that kopi I use kpi's as a barometer
of how they're doing based on where they
want to get to hmm and I think that's
the biggest deal how did you call rate
that in recruitment which is a very lot
of being that like the business that I
was in I've it was [ __ ] competitive
like I'm you know I mean so how how have
you gone about cultivating yeah the
right culture and the right team culture
where they know that you're gonna help
them and you've got their best interests
at heart but you've also got my
colleague who I'm competing with
technically best interests as world you
know I mean so how did you how have you
sort of helps that Orkut helped
cultivate that well I fit a fee you know
we quite quick to criticize in life
aren't we yeah and one of the one of the
going back to when I did read a book
when I was thirty it was about little
things as a manager you know saying
hello there's really basic things saying
and loads of people saying well done for
a good choir lit money I need well done
tiny little things we all need a little
bit of a pat on the back don't win it is
early an efficient sales and recruitment
yeah
but I think there's a lot of times where
people say that's not good cool that's
not you know that's not least trying to
look for people for things that people
do well and you know if I get someone so
well done to me for anything
even as a grown man 15 years experience
and guess I feel like that silly little
smile on my face I'm trying to hide but
I'm really happy
yeah so I think just the cultivating
an environment where everyone is happy
for everyone else's success yeah and I
think that comes from the top
yeah you know for you you know you you
say well done here and there and you you
raise people's profile internally but
also making sure that everyone is trying
to do something different push
themselves I'm not worried about making
mistakes
yeah I'm not criticizing when people
make a mistake if they tried to do
something yeah if you make the mistake
when you've done it you know you've been
told twice that's a bit different is
there but certainly encouraging people
to be better and encouraging people to
be good human beings and I think it's
also you as a manager understanding what
people's will you talk about the vision
and where they're going that you can't
paint everyone's vision the same with
the same brush can you so understanding
where where people are motivated to get
to and what drives them and those things
as well isn't it you need to get you
need to know your people don't you sauce
yeah each person in the business I could
tell you exactly what their motive a
tourism yeah when they're drivers but
but then at the start of the year what
we do is break down right why are you
here why are you doing what you do why
are you gonna get all these knock backs
and working out whether they want a car
a house and then working out how much
the need to get that hmm and then
breaking down their weekly KPI is based
on what they want to achieve in life so
if you only want to earn that much
that's fine then that's what you do on a
daily basis but if you want to learn
that this is what you don't know is so
that it's real for people everything
everyone does every day is real yeah and
it means something too so if you've got
your picture old you know we start
pictures of cars or we wanted that
vision board a vision just yeah I like
know what if you don't know where you're
going you don't know when you get there
yeah and I think that's really important
for people yeah right at the start of
the year what do you want and why are
you doing this job and this is what you
need to do on a daily basis so yeah
using KPIs as a barometer against that
yeah as opposed to summits abash them
over the head believes that don't do it
now you could say to people you know if
you wanted a car to start the year give
him giving consultants the freedom
that's good mate so before we go into
the dark days beginning there's a void
decks then so you mentioned all to you
the
the Golden Boy at one point so what was
your best year Billings was was it a
read or has it been ident it's been
idec's actually so I'm not a huge bill
except obviously I've got excuses
because I'm managing the business as
well but I'm certainly not the million
pounds being a [ __ ]
250 okay yeah yeah but consistently
doing there in that year on you so
that's my excuse yeah but we've got guys
in the business now that are much better
consultants for me really and that's
good yeah and that's really I think
that's you know I think if you if you
grow in a business and you want to be
the top Billa then your business isn't
going to thrive yeah and that's my
disclaimer for not doing more than two
very we've got we've got a going out our
business now that's doing you know six
seven hundred plus [ __ ] honey and
he's you know he's a phenomenon in terms
of how he operates and what he does and
he's a technician and he's beautiful to
what you mean in his superb I recruited
him 10 years ago and he's much better
than me as a consultant yeah that's fine
yeah
so I think you know if that's that's
what he should be about I think if you
are going into management going back to
your earlier question yeah you you
should be looking for people to become
better than you yeah and don't worry
about that because no way then yeah
otherwise you get in the way of their
progression yeah and so I think you
should always be a taste of real
humility like job security as well yeah
you know does take a lot of humility to
do but I was always told you should be
looking to recruit people better than
you when you were like if you do that
whether year in recruitment or in
financial services or if you look to
recruit people better than you then your
business is gonna thrive as a result of
it okay so why did you join nine decks
and when things were all going good
I think it was a man clearly had an
impact and yet had a massive impact you
know he had a big big draw on it really
had an opportunity to to go with Matt
when he first set up and at the time I
was just having my first kid and yeah
I couldn't risk yeah couldn't afford not
to learn for that period of time so I
joined I think was about 12 months later
and I did that because I felt that
working for a big national you couldn't
you would driven by
kpi's and targets that weren't in the
best interests of the client and
candidate interesting and and you know I
think there was some some poor practice
going on while saying this I'm not
knocking because it was a good grinding
but certainly I think we could create a
business that was built on what our
clients and candidates want as opposed
to what we wanted from a profit level or
anything like so we actually looked at
the clients looked at the candidates and
built the business back from what they
wanted as opposed to you'll around yeah
class and I love I love that opportunity
and it was yeah we said it from day one
that's the part that you loved right so
yeah I'd totally get out I mean that but
at the same time if you work for a big
corporate the only way they're gonna be
able to manage this success is having
those [ __ ] KPI isn't everything else
in there yes understanding unlike any
you have 2k player myself but even now
we've got what 40 45 people in our
business but each individual in our
business has completely different KPIs
yeah because that each person has a
different desk there was different
ratios different goals different goals
and motivation so so we're even at our
size now where most phones will get to
our size and have the same kpi's across
the board we haven't done that and each
person has their own individual desk
KPIs that the word towards based on what
their desk did last year type of
relationship okay mate so let's talk
about those dark days then let's talk
about that it's a light so yeah so yeah
so you join them you decides just to
whet hold office say obviously I do your
children etc join them financial crisis
so let's talk a bit about that because
it's hard for me to really comprehend
that how are you about 26 right so I've
never had to I haven't I haven't
experienced that right and not there'll
be a few people now bricks it and all
these things well I'm no I'm no
politician I don't follow them these are
yeah yeah but like like let's talk a bit
about that life well actually was that
like I think it's hard to put into it
unless you actually experienced it it's
hard I remember at one point thinking
what career am I going to do now because
recruitment will never be a job again it
was that bad you know amazing you're
picking up at the time we were picking
up you know one two jobs a month
was that bad really but what we were
fortunate RVs because we looked after
our clients there kind of felt sorry for
us when we said business if they did
have any work or any jobs that come here
they give it to us so we actually
benefited over the big Nationals because
the kind of their felt for us their
newest that experienced me move they
knew I had a kid yeah then you know so
at least I had the relation and that's
why he kind of taught me to look after
you clients always yes they're the ones
that look after you and need you so if
it does happen again I've got enough
client relationships enough people that
I've looked after him serviced yeah
hopefully you know that they'll give us
some business but I don't I think it's
hard to actually put into words but I'm
talking about you know it was it was
difficult to get any interviews you know
candidates was it was the hardest thing
was candidates that he knew and clients
that he knew and had worked with for
years were being made redundant and the
whole lives at work were you know on the
line I guess really because he's lots of
jobs and you've got people genuinely
crying on the phone saying they'd lost
the job and not being able to get
anything else early so you became from a
recruiter to a Samaritan really seconds
and it genuinely felt that way and I see
now but you're also at the same time I
think you've done if I'm gonna have a
Chavez I've just done this move and that
sort of stuff something had on that gone
for it was probably about eighteen
months yeah a long time so I mean you've
how did he sound the fight you get
through that with great difficulty with
the support of my when our wife and Matt
Matt Matt was great you know we had to
we had to work around the finances and
work a lot of things out but again
that's what I'm talking about you took
that's merely about my knock backs and
that was a knock back anything I learned
more in that year and a half and I've
learned in the 10 years subsequently
yeah because you learn what's important
you learn not to get too carried away
with yourself you learn to ride the
successes and understand that the faith
you know I've got it was it was really
bad way you've it can turn at any point
carnie I'm in a position now hopefully
that it wouldn't happen like that again
but it teaches you a lot and that's
where I get the thing where I look for
people that dealt with adverse
I know I learned more from that year and
a half when times are really tough than
after them from the ten years of success
after that as well yeah that's class and
so one of the biggest learnings through
that then was like Yuri realizes that
clients the people that you need to make
sure that you really double down on that
relationship
absolutely yeah yeah yeah look uh I
think you know always do the right thing
by everyone why by your clients I guess
that's the thing is they and if they've
done that then they'll do right by you
in future yeah but also as I was saying
earlier don't get too carried away we
success mm-hmm you know you can build to
three million pounds but one economic
factor or one change can suddenly change
that so don't get too carried away
because at the end of our recruiters
aren't we and I think people get too
carried away with the right sense of
yeah and so nothing you know I've been
through times when I've seen someone go
from a 300 brambilla to nothing below
because of one change in the economy so
things can change quickly so just stay
grounded yeah like that let's talk a bit
more about that I really like how you've
mentioned that quite a few times now
because if I think back nah I don't like
this that's why I was like talking about
mindset and those things because like
how many how many really successful
billa's are getting pulled aside and
getting spoken about about finances
about about and their mental health
well-being and how to yeah keep grounded
and have that humility you know I mean
it seems like you really approach it
that way so like what is it has it has
it always been like that have you always
been that open to those conversation to
you said like your big brothers you have
those conversations like to make them
aware like look don't get ahead of
yourself did you know I mean like yeah I
think the big bill is now business so a
little bit more worldly wise than that
but I think it's more when you first
come in in the first three years if
you've got people coming down from 25
grand earnings to 50 grand and you're
talking about people doubling their yes
I certainly think we had a company
coming in talk to us about financial
education to try and give people some
pointers of what to do with their money
because it's quite easy to you know I've
done it myself when you first start
billing yeah you get some money on the
board and you've spent the money before
even you see that's how they advertise
recruitment now to young people to get
in this the Rolexes it's there
it's not me honestly it's not well what
I'm saying that well but there's lots of
different types of firms isn't it yeah
the majority of funds if you went online
and you look to what they promote in
terms of work on their work for us page
look at these yeah a lot the go-to is OB
for trips incentives nation Rolex or
that yeah so you know I mean yeah what I
do I do know what you mean but we
promote certain aspects of success but
success doesn't always mean money does
it so if people are promoting money is
the driving factor of people joining
them they're gonna get a certain type of
individual aren't they yeah so I guess
you know if we talk to any business
about how to recruit you you advertise
based on the type of individual want to
attract of course if you have Attar's
purely based on money then you're gonna
get the type of individuals oh he's only
interested in money or Salazar yeah so I
guess you know if that's what business
is how so how so how have you Cole how
have you just start to communicate that
to these people because all of a sudden
you're going from being their manager to
being a bit of a life thing I don't know
you know I mean it's like has it just
naturally happen where you've sat these
people down and this is what I learned
through getting more money I can see
that you're doing really well now why
it's you know I mean it's not my job to
guide them is it because you know so we
got a fermion to come and talk about
financial change that specifically focus
on going into corporate businesses and
talking about financial well-being cool
so we've done that I've had a mindset
coach come in so a lot of the trailer
that we do yeah he's not well it's not
on sales training because really why
would you train someone on sales if
they're mindsets
poor yeah does that point see you better
off training on the mindset getting
people positive getting people to
understand each other and we've had some
great sessions where you you sitting man
you've got all the team talking about
things that you just didn't realize
about them and yeah that the bonding of
the team as well that is great so
mindset I think he's important but also
yeah a bit of and that's where the team
sort of see that you trying to do right
by them hmm you know we don't have to
pay for someone to come in and educate
them on Finance yes no I like that some
what we do because it's so much more
people just need to be
having those conversations because it's
like there's [ __ ] mid-20 lot obviously
wasn't me I build 24 K in my first year
look I know there's mid like [ __ ] 25
rolls out there driving Aston Martin's
and [ __ ] like that
it's like look it you know I mean like
there's more to it than this has to mind
all that like what is your plan what is
your financial well-being or this yeah
that's that's life generally that's the
country generally isn't it the nice
little education piece exactly but
ultimately as a recruitment you know
manager business owner whatever you want
to do I guess it's just trying to what
what do you people need to make them
successful in life and you know money if
you waste it he's not gonna help that so
I guess it's just making sure that
you're trying to give people the
education that they need and to make
sure they get to a point when they leave
I'd Excel for life that's what I do we
can get people that ourself for life
leaving our decks that's perfect
even if they set up against our decks at
least if they've done ten ten years for
us or and done done a great job if to
set up against us as long as not taking
our clients for 12 months restrictive
covenant in you service and they leave
is a good math class it looked to them
yeah that's classmate so let's talk a
bit about after the recession and them
what's been going on since then so but
how how BIG's your team now services
we've got 13 across the country so we've
broken that down we've we've just niched
really we should probably should have
done sooner really well it's been a
benefit to that then
underst having an intricate knowledge of
the specific markets and the people
within those markets more importantly I
think we're we were specialists that
were gem lifts really generally
specialists whatever we're especially
its but reason was that because what you
would let's say you've got a financial
services for and
what would you recruit to many of the
roles that you could recruit for you
know I mean was there double done
certain sectors within the business that
you just focused on as opposed to I'll
do all of it yeah we kind of would just
get whatever we we could grab hold of I
guess at one yes
I think certainly the last three years
we've you know increased our average fee
by about 30% really yeah which has been
a great exercise I'll [ __ ] be done
that all starts started saying no to
things and started positioning ourselves
differently so we were kind of mid tier
in terms of the they let me start doing
more like retained in Lyon yeah with the
more more retains we're up about 50 60
percent in terms of the retain work that
we'd do but also we positioned ourselves
differently in the market and we're
looking at different things really we're
trying to get more senior work and
that's were as well so we've got less
clients now which was quite difficult to
do he's cutting clients and I know
that's difficult yeah so we've now got
less clients and we've ever had but we
do more business um we've ever done and
also you know we're working less jobs
and we've ever worked for jobs more
focus yeah yeah absolutely so you know
we great great our jobs which has worked
really well really so we're trying to
work work things that we know we can so
when you save already Georgie or what
yeah your work because you have to learn
that quick and cream and you will just
work [ __ ] anything so yeah what you
mean by that your your consultants or
working jobs that one they've got the
relationship where their client is gonna
take their phone calls I need help or
whatever
yeah but working jobs that they know is
really important to their client and
they know that they're gonna get paid
yes I think we know what we've done is
you've put a process in place so that
new joiners you were talking about new
joiners earlier may I do for them giving
them understanding of what a job that
you can fill ease yeah a fillable job
sorry yeah so you know we have a jobs be
jobs and CDs okay so we just purely
focused on getting the jobs that we can
fill and that's based on the client
relationship where it is money all that
sort of stuff yeah but they've got
literally drop boxes of what they tick
off to make sure that it's an a job and
they can only work roles but that you
know that are a or B basically I like
that so actually yeah our clients of
half die average fees increased and our
job fills doubled [ __ ] out yes so we
how long how long does that transition
being you think taken against that point
three years really he's one of those I
wish we did just done it from the star
as you
I'm sure everyone's like that but if
we'd have done that from the start we'd
probably be much further ahead than we
are at them yeah but but it's so how
clients take how how why is it their
clients are willing to pay more than and
they filled in you know I'm in well
they're not a suit paying us more we're
just working on high-level roles I'm
sorry ok ok ok ok so the average fee in
terms of the total amount as I put the
percentage yeah so we're working on high
level roles now and that's what we're
focusing on really so but we're telling
people that's what we do
yeah that makes sense you get back what
you put out there for Europe you were
generalist you'll get generalist roles
yeah the sights of people this is
monisha and this is what I do then
that's what you get by simply and
because I had to be fair I've had a few
I've had a few conversations actually
finding stuff where people like layer
we're trying to yeah we're trying to
penetrate that a higher level with the
bigger salary bracket and then that's
literally in short simply it's like tell
everyone that's what you do do that's
how you can help yeah yeah as I say you
get back what you put out though so if
you tell people this is what I do then
that's what you get yeah you know so so
we've had a lot of success with that but
also going out and and pitching yeah I
think recruitment a lot probably went
through phases a lot of people do where
people hiding behind either the phone or
in phones great but even worse hiding
behind email you know getting in front
of people and actually pitching our
services to people and what we can do to
help their business and make them better
yeah and I've loved that going out in
front of chief execs directors and
actually you know old-fashioned
PowerPoint and talking about right this
is what we can do this is how we can
help you yeah and this is where we'll go
stand talking about the recruitment
process as a whole as opposed to the
products which is the candidate yeah
like that so that's that's good mate
it's a few things on the dive into begin
to get you or your perspective firstly
so you mentioned that early on you built
a desk from scratch and all these things
had a couple of messages recently about
some if you can if I could ask people
about some advice that's for pharma
recruit I'm going into a recruitment
agency and I've got this cold desk it's
fonteneau's Java development and they're
making art but it's a cold desk what
what would be sort of your you go to
advice for that person if they're
they're building a god that cold that's
what scratch would be something you're
from your experience
well I mean it was always told don't put
green on green so I think you need a
decent recruits down but for the first
thing is to research and the key players
in the market okay so map out your
market map out your market who's the key
companies that recruiting yeah and who
are the key contacts at those businesses
yeah and get in front of them again
pitch to them mm-hm
you know that's the keys need don't be
hot don't hide behind who are they who
are the big businesses who were the big
contacts there get out this attack that
peach to them or what might be a bit
aggressive in front of them and talk
about how you can help their business
yeah that's a because I think what I've
seen recently for the first time in my
15-year career in recruitment is it's
actually seen as a profession you know I
honestly believe that you think I
honestly do yet I think because of the
challenges of people being able to
recruit and the you know the key part
for any any key challenge for any chief
exec at the moment is recruitment right
it is you know any statistic PD BC did
one I'm not gonna quote another the
exact figure where that was the biggest
challenge for see yeah
so if that's the case and you're a
recruiter you can genuinely help people
solve their businesses better you know
that's what we're looking for we're
looking for that we can solve so I think
I think you've got a couple that we've
like you got a really believe in that
you you can't solve that problem as well
do you not I mean know you've got you
clearly believe in yourself there I'm
solving a real problem
yeah proud to be recruiter I can help
your business yeah whereas there will be
a lot of people where obviously work
women has such a bad name and recruiters
are then they're not trusted people but
a lot of that because I think me
industries even listen to these podcasts
now there's so much so much quality out
there yeah there's some real some poor
practice out there and one of the things
I remember from the recession is that
that was the good thing that happened
was the poor recruiters were strata the
marquees here and don't survive in them
yeah in a tough market is a poor
recruiter but I think there's some
really high standard I agree going on
the map in the moment but will would
become regulated one day or would we not
be mad
well off you know I went and got my
qualification with the wreck and I think
that we've got eight people in our
business that did that really I mean
what are recording a lot of phone calls
in that sort of not being regulated
where you have to be qualified with the
Breck or whatever the governing body is
to be able to do the job yeah that's
interesting
so surely there's you know everything is
becoming regulated I'm sure there's
gonna be a time in McCrimmon where that
will happen in the next three to five
six well gdpr
should have stopped some poor practices
but he hasn't you know you still got
we've still got people in the market
just firing out CVS haven't suppose and
stuff like you know that still happens
but surely has got to come a time where
yeah there's gonna be some regulation
put in place I'm not you know a lot of
recruiters will listen to the end state
shut up stop saying that but it's gonna
come a point where that happens and
would that be a bad thing tonight if
we're talking about the profession
hasn't I think he it is a better
profession now but if we're talking
about it not having that view in the
marketplace would it be a bad yeah I
sure okay one finger if we wanted to get
your perspective of is your clear
someone that has a humility to encourage
people to be better than you and all
these things so like I always like
asking this like what what have been
through your through your career what
have been the things that are prevented
recruit is going from 250 a year to 350
to 450 like what have been the common
habits or common things that you've seen
that people breaking through to get to
that that next level
you think the the next level offered
least least we could probably got three
or four that are at that level okay and
and what's taking them up he's having
someone come in okay that the push that
suddenly shut raise the bar you know we
were a business really two years ago
where we didn't think anyone could do
more than a certain level of income in
the markets that we operate at and then
suddenly someone came in that the you
know 50 percent more than everyone else
and everybody else raised as it was all
of you heard the flea analogy no right
so if you get a jar with some fleas in
yeah put your hand over the top of it
the fleas don't jump above your hand
when you move it okay if you then put
another flea yeah that jumps above the
the jar and then all the other fleas
follow it okay
so if you can get that that consultant
that comes in that's like a 4-minute
marna well yeah that's exactly what is
so yeah you know you need to find your
flea basically so I think what stop
people from getting to that next level
is believing that it's possible possible
here what sir
I didn't think a million-pound was
possible so slightly since these pod
hair didn't you know some of the people
do million quid I'm like how are you
doing that
yeah suddenly my mindsets changed he's
right if people are doing a million
pound
oh those stories that you tell yourself
isn't it are can only get probably do
another 250 this year it's it's the old
thing you need to see to believe it
don't you yeah if I tell you that you
can do a million pound it's you know
difficult but if there's a guy that sat
next to us that's doing it yeah then
then people believe so I think the thing
that stops anyone from doing anything is
the belief that they can actually do it
mmm
so I think you know ultimately we can do
anything come so that person then
obviously it's like I'm sitting there
and there's a lot [ __ ] our this guy's
done 600k this year like no it's
possible right but where the end of it
what was he doing anything different you
know I mean like was there anything in
there that you noticed as like that's
really interesting well this guy for us
that's doing 16 ok again I would say his
name but then they feel like that could
in love yeah and also might get edited I
mean you know for but you know series
but four or five years ago you know he
had a really tough run and he Kenny but
he didn't change throughout that he
didn't change the way I operate didn't
change the way worked and I think he had
a year waiting like 50 60 grand you know
really really poor you but we knew it
was a good recruiter yeah and he kept
doing the same things but he believed in
himself and he followed that same
process and he built his network so that
that's you know that's fantastic to see
really so you had a real structure you
had the really believed in this
structure
he's probably did but also he'd seen
someone else come into the business that
had done 500 and he then believed he
could see cuz I don't think he'd seen
that before so he'd seen someone do it
and he stayed doing more of the things
that he did well
okay so it's recognizing the things that
you do well we are what I'll do more of
it and ultimately the guy works longer
hours there's anybody else you know
really he's gonna manage so many
placements oh yeah but he's the guy that
would be enough we still 10
[ __ ] really he'd be the and I was
talking about when he was doing fifty
grand man that takes a lot of motivation
to when you're not doing well ten hours
yeah okay now yeah so I think then and
that's what I don't see as much anymore
in recruitment I used to see a lot of
people working til eight nine o'clock in
the office yeah you don't see that
anymore everyone wants the culture
everyone wants the niceness agile work
you know last yeah listen first two
years you were talking about what you
did the first few years
yeah work longer and harder than anyone
else that's what I did more than anyone
else talk about the science behind it
motivation and mentality and all that
sort of stuff but ultimately the first
two years you get into recruitment you
work hard there when else yeah but soon
one else yeah you can [ __ ] control
analysis but 15 years in recruitment and
one coming at you is my advice he's
worked really hard that's not science is
he but ultimately if you look at what
these guys do you can you can give all
the the tools and all the different
things you can do but the guy that is
our biggest pillar is the one that does
the most hours and I don't think that's
also a coincidence but he also balances
out with his life and all that sort of
stuff so yeah yeah so if you don't a
million-pound you can't rely I think
that's totally true and someone just
seen something around you raising the
bar realizing that they're no different
to you know that's that's such a
game-changer in it I think that's a
great thing about podcasts and all the
information I've access to it it's like
well hang on a minute no that person's
done I can definitely do that but it
everyone is fascinating than once okay
well well how long has he spent beading
or like how long has he spent sourcing
or how Z structure is dead you know I
mean everyone wants that little that
little secret or that little bit that's
gonna they think it's gonna help them
get yeah well I mean I mean that that
he's just working things he you know you
know you're gonna make money off isn't
it yeah yeah you know someone gave me
someone where I think there was a
company where the job field was 20% okay
so you fill in one in five jobs that
comes in yeah and the best analogy I had
was if you're a plumber and you were
going to do five jobs and you're only
gonna get paid on one yeah which one
would you work on you know so so but
that's what we do isn't it week written
we spend a lot of time why not get
not getting paid for a lot of work that
we do yeah so you have to choose
carefully the work that you take on on
the work that you do based on the client
relationship you've got so I think yeah
that combined with hard work and then ya
know like that anything that you wanna
add I really like that anything you
wanna add on on the mindset piece I feel
like you've you've got you you're pretty
switched on and well you know I mean
like gee do you have open conversations
about I know you said you've got a
mindset coach all those things like what
what did anyone speak about mindset when
you starting light you know I mean in
the early early years oh well it was
more had in sports there's a lot of
things that happen in sports now that we
can bring into business with sports
science and yeah good stuff so I had it
really in terms of mine sense
I'm sorry mine say but I think the
challenge we've got now is there's a lot
of talk around mental health yeah I
think the biggest thing we need is
education to people as to what mental
health is ah you know I mean that's why
as a lot of mental health awareness he's
great
but there's also we've seen a lot of
people saying well I'm mentally unwell
because something Bad's happened in
their life so I think you know we need
to get to a point where they need some
in education on what mental healthy and
that could that can help with the
mindset coach is because they taught you
about what you need to do to make
yourself happy as well so I think
mindset coaches can help with the mental
well-being and mental health as well you
need to do to make you self mentally
healthy it's the same as going the
Jimmy's need to make yourself fit you
know you need to do the same sort of
things on a daily basis to make make
sure you mind is fit and strong yeah the
same way that you do with your buddy
surfing the mindset coach I think he's
he's really really important or
certainly people understanding how the
mind works let me complicate yes okay
we're just [ __ ] we're doesn't mean we
are well we are well we can put the mind
can easily tell you that you're a weirdo
yeah I couldn't agree more that's why
I'm I was really motivated to get some
people on and talk about mental health
because like now live on LinkedIn and
spend a lot of time on there and I just
I just feel like it's a very easy word
to use now and I think at the same time
it's dangerous but it's great that
people more people talking about at the
same time it's like I don't know I don't
I don't personally I don't like it when
people are they're really tough with my
mental health this week okay
what do you mean yeah who needs a bit
more context you know I mean I think
there needs to be as you said the
natural just education around it so
because the more people that actually
understand how their brain works and all
these things the better
exactly absolutely so mental health I
guess just going back it's for the for
the good in terms of you know using mind
to make sure you believe that you can do
and believe that you can get and talk to
these CEOs but also to make sure you
don't eat when you're getting these
knock backs someone saying I'm not gonna
work with you it doesn't mean that you
go in next before and we start wrapping
up mate light again I always ask people
what's opposite women to go every stuff
like that and a real common one again is
that resilient piece and I know you've
gave a few stories and all those things
you look for that and people and these
things so like how do you some people as
you said like that girl that started
just broke a heart you can do a bit I
think there's got to be a bit of self
awareness ago you know what this isn't
for me that's part of it but how do you
really instill that resilience in people
do not I mean there you've got a player
part to play in that a bit as well
surely or not well I'm not sure you can
really yeah I'm not sure you can so what
do you need you reverse it you without
stop sign so you are that's how you
write you know how you brought up or
what's happened to you when you're in
your early life or people have had the
parents divorce all these all these
little things or big things that happen
in your life that create that ability to
overcome adversity so that's what I look
for it because I know that you could
train it yeah I don't think you can
train it when someone joins if they
haven't been managed and you know that
that perfect that recruiter who has
shown a bit resilience in the past and
having a bit of a ship two months three
months four months yeah what you do
how'd you get him to do not mean push
through the resilience how do you keep
well how old family I can I can tell
them that they've been through much
worse than their life and that's
happening at the moment and that came
about much stronger in their yeah
they're much better as a result of it so
understand and ask people what they've
learnt from the bad experience yeah you
know if someone's going wrong what have
you learned from it and what you're
gonna do to change that and impact that
moving forward yeah and I think if you
just ask people questions don't you know
that telling people so yourself out you
ask people questions so what have you
learnt from these three months forget
about having a tough time it's again
focusing on dis
what we learned what we do differently
next time yeah you know get people to
enjoy the failure love it yeah that's
that's that's the thing if you can it's
a really messed up mindset but if you
can learn to enjoy your failures then
everyday I'll be okay I'm equivalent but
do you do anything personally to help me
like I always like asking that like any
did you have for many habits to get
through those [ __ ] times like tonight
yeah the habit is changing my mindset to
see a failure okay a success yes that
simple as that yeah
failure a lot of times you think oh man
I've done that wrong I'm terrible old
are but if you looking go wow and that's
what I miss the next time when you do
the deal or whatever is happening you
you you remember that failure and you
you do differently so going back to what
you say he's just looking at my changed
my mind to see a failures yeah all comes
down to mind say Nancy view point but
you know we're in a great job that's you
know really straightforward isn't it but
it's the most difficult simple job in
the world is the improvement yeah but
there's lots of different things just
make sure you would you adapt to how you
work in trying be better all the time
and don't get too carried away with
successes or failures yeah and trying
that's big enough yes they grant that's
like when I Rolexes kids to keep it real
right before we finish me and I'd be
keen to just get your focus on this
because yeah I really like how and how
positively you're talking about the
industry and and and that's a big part
well I started this if I'm on it's light
to give actual people real a real
perspective into the industry right so
where did where do you think
recruitments going over the next couple
years I think it's most personally I
think it's the most exciting time for a
while and I think the minutes of I think
you've got an industry where the clients
need you yeah you know so that's great
there's a lead from clients and there's
a respect for what we do and for our
profession and the way we operate if you
do it properly and I think there's all
the technology that's coming in place
and all that you know if you go to any
of these events about what's happening
with tech and AI and stuff like there's
some really exciting stuff that's gonna
be happening in the industry so I
actually think it's a great time to be
part of it yeah so I'll see becoming
more innovative more career
the firms that dare to be different will
be the best ones yeah turn them I think
it's dare to be different and then also
double down on those relationships and
double down on [ __ ] delivering for
their clients the people that know the
clients inside out and the ones that
leash you have Tunisia share I wish we'd
have done it sooner we didn't but all
the people that I see you know I top
three pillars are the ones that have got
the narrowest niche really so actually I
used to think when you come into
recruitment if you had the biggest
database the most clients those
candidates that was the best one yeah
actually less is more and I think you
start to see that less is more and you
nice down in game could be a game
changer but the industry is an exciting
place to be nice mate so look what
before actually the last question mate
what were you excited about in your
world mate what is going on what's going
on denied excellent idec's yeah I'm
excited about about I'm excited about
the number of people we've got that are
better than last year oh I'm excited
good yeah yeah I'm excited about the
quality of client relationships we've
got and I'm excited that we're
innovating and we try new things and we
going out and putting in technology that
other firms haven't got and we're trying
to Aaron to be different yeah we're
daring to be different and we're
observing the masses and doing the
opposite which is you know I think you
know if we're in a business that was
stagnating and wasn't trying to be
better or do things differently then
it'd be really boring but we're doing
that which means that every day is
different every year is different and
that's what it's about in it last night
so last question one last question yeah
so yeah you can answer it with a phrase
sentence if you could communicate to
everyone they'd listen to you
all the recruiters in the world they
listen to you there take one advice what
would you say it could be a phrase could
be a sentence what have you got to say
to these people that you really want
them to listen to don't be a [ __ ] I
like that yeah it's not the first person
to say am i oh really
no but I think yeah I think he knows a
lot that the industry the challenge of
got as industries
one of those because they're carried
away on their own successor so don't get
carried away with your own success I
like it yeah don't be a dick heads bad I
mean again I like it look be an absolute
pleasure making my thank you so much
thanks